Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, der Jens Spahn, der ist schon wieder seinen Job los. Haben wir vielleicht,
für den eine Beschäftigung?
Ähm, warte mal.
Also mir fällt echt nichts an, wofür man den gebrauchen könnte.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 561,
vom 29. September 2026. Und hier in der netzpolitischen Jobbörse,
da geht es schon mal rund.
Also wird ja vermittelt und so weiter, die Kompetenzen werden überprüft und,
so bestücken wir dann die Intelligenz dieses Landes aber ich glaube für Jens ist da kein Platz,
Ne.
Für den wüsste ich jetzt echt nicht.
Also er hat sich irgendwie nicht jetzt unbedingt von deiner besten Seite gezeigt.
Ich glaube, das hat er ja.
Meinst du, das war schon die beste Seite, die wir da gesehen haben?
Das heißt ja, dass auf der anderen Seite das ist ja noch schlimm.
Na die andere Seite, da ranken sich ja Gerüchte.
Ach wirklich, Gerüchte?
Ja, die kannst du, also nee, dann musst du alles nachher wieder rausschneiden
hier aus der Sennzeitssendung.
Das machen wir nicht. Das machen wir nicht. Das ist ja ein seriöses Fachmagazin hier.
Jo, dann machen wir. Achso, wollte ich noch sagen, Fun Facts.
Ja, da warst du mal. War ich ja mal.
Man will ja Fun Facts unterstützen und Bandenmitglied werden und Like,
Subscribe, Glocke auf YouTube und die,
Peertube-Links posten und so weiter und so fort.
Und interessanterweise wurde ich nochmal gefragt, ich will nochmal eine Sendung
machen und habe in einem Anflug vollständiger geistiger Umnachtung zugesagt.
Oh.
17. November, das ist Dienstag in Berlin, wieder im Mehringhof-Theater.
Mache ich wieder eine Folge. Ich habe noch keine Ahnung worüber,
aber da fällt mir schon was ein.
Macht euch aber keine Sorgen, bei Logbuch Netzpolitik weiß ich auch nicht einen
Monat vorher, was wir da erzählen.
Also was von dem, was wir immer wieder erzählen, wir dann in der Woche erzählen.
Okay, und gibt es schon Tickets?
Ich glaube ja. So erfahre ich das ja.
Achso, weil du einfach gelistet wirst sozusagen. Da rufe ich einfach meinen
Booker an und dann eine Woche vorher nicht. Nee, ich hab tatsächlich.
Es war so, ich hab ein bisschen so, als wir das vereinbart hatten,
war das so ein bisschen...
Schien das noch so fern und unverbindlich. Und letztes Mal habe ich das ja auch
quasi dadurch erfahren, dass es dann einfach die Tickets gab.
Ja.
So sind die.
Verstehe. Okay.
Genau, 17.11. 18.15 Uhr, Einlass, 19 Uhr, Beginn im Mehringhof-Theater in der
Gneisenau-Straße 2A in Berlin.
Ticketlink kann man auch nochmal in die Shownotes machen.
Ja, das wollte ich auch nochmal kurz erzählen.
Ich habe ja noch einmal das nochmal. Ich gucke gerade mal.
17. Das ist ja schon was gelistet. Das sieht, ach, gucke mal,
da lächelst du einem ja schon an.
Mhm.
Ah, Lausbub. Na gut, das packen wir doch gleich in die Show Notes für euch. Alright.
Genau. Vielleicht machen wir eine Sendung über KI. Das haben wir letztes Mal geschaut.
Guck dir mal was Neues aus. Ja, ich bin auch nur ein spachischer Papagei.
Tim. Ich sag einfach, das wird als nächstes...
Und der einfach so in den Sinn kommt, oder?
Einfach nur so.
Einfach so.
Völlig geheim.
Also, es gab wildes Feedback zur letzten Sendung. In dem...
Einige Dinge bemerkt wurden.
Und zwar habe ich sinngemäß so etwas gesagt wie, dass das Modell erst etwas
falsch macht und sich dann selber verbessert.
Das heißt nicht, dass das Modell besser wird, sondern dass es quasi seinen eigenen
Fehler korrigiert oder sein eigenes Output in einer zweiten Runde verbessert.
Genauso wie ich, wenn ich einen Fehler mache und den verbessere und sage,
ich habe mich selber verbessert,
dann heißt das nicht, dass ich als Ergebnis ein besserer Mensch geworden bin,
sondern nur, dass ich halt quasi einen Fehler erkannt und ihn beseitigt habe.
Das war also nicht gemeint, dass damit das Modell quasi während es quasi agiert
und seine Lernphase vorbei ist, noch weiter lernen würde.
Wohl aber werden natürlich die Interaktionen und Fortschritte und Sessions,
die wir als beispielsweise Nutzerinnen von Cloud gehosteten Services durchführen,
sehr wohl genutzt, um die nächste Generation zu trainieren.
Also quasi, um zu sehen, pass auf, hier, das war der erste Anlauf,
aber der richtige ist erst der dritte, so macht man das.
Genauso wie die Modelle eben natürlich auch, glaube ich, habe ich auch letzte
Sendung durchaus erklärt oder besprochen, sich durch ein Git-Repository durchfräsen
und halt nicht nur den Jetzt-Stand lesen, sondern eben auch,
wie ist man da hingekommen, weil man dadurch natürlich,
gut lernen kann, wie man es gleich hätte richtig machen können.
Zeitmaschine, das müsste man mal regulieren.
Bei der Forderung bleibe ich, da lasse ich mich auch nicht von abbringen.
Dann,
würde sich so ein bisschen darüber,
echauffiert, es wären ja so, in mehreren Kommentaren, das wären ja alles nur
stochastische Papageien und jetzt würde suggeriert, das wären handelnde oder
planvoll handelnde Wesen.
Also,
dieser Begriff des stochastischen Papageis, der ist weiterhin zutreffend,
wenn aber die Wortfolgen ausreichend quasi die Wahrscheinlichkeit oder,
quasi der Detailgrad, mit dem die Wahrscheinlichkeit des nächsten Tokens,
aufgelöst wird, wenn die halt groß genug ist oder wenn der fein genug ist,
dann lassen sich eben auch mit dieser einfachen Idee, mal gucken,
was der nächste Wahrscheinliche ist, halt extrem komplexe Sachverhalte abbilden und auflösen.
Und das ist das, was wir jetzt sehen bei diesen Modellen. dass sie eben mehrere
Sprachen beherrschen und komplexe Sinnzusammenhänge,
sich abbilden in dieser Herleitung der nächsten wahrscheinlichsten Silbe.
Also dieser Mechanismus kann offenbar.
Obwohl er quasi zunächst einmal den Eindruck macht, dass es quasi eine Limitation darstellen würde.
Es gibt nämlich keine, es gibt ja auch für stochastische oder statistische Systeme keine Obergrenze.
Ich würde sogar sagen, die kann es auch gar nicht geben,
weil sämtliche Inferenzstatistik natürlich auch immer das Ziel hat und übrigens
auch die zumindest epistemologische Grundannahme,
dass sämtliche Zusammenhänge vollständig aufklärbar sind und man nur limitiert darin ist,
wie viel man von dem Kontext erfasst hat und deswegen nur Anteile der Variationen,
die wir wahrnehmen, tatsächlich aufklären kann.
Aber es ist nicht, man geht trotzdem davon aus, dass quasi alles vollständig
aufklärbar ist. Wir haben nur noch nicht alles Relevante erfasst.
Also ich meine, dieser Vergleich mit den Papageien, der wird ja dann gerne in
so Diskussionen auf den Tisch geworfen, so mit dem Argument,
naja, aber so eine AI ist ja nur so ein stochastischer Papagei.
Da frage ich mich dann immer so, vielleicht sind wir das ja auch nur.
Ja, und der Beweis steht übrigens nur, der gegenteilige Beweis steht aus.
Ja, aber ich meine mal ehrlich, vielleicht ist es ja sogar so,
dass diese Maschinen, ich sage nicht, das ist so, ich sage nur,
das kann sein, da wirklich jetzt etwas nachgebildet haben, was bei uns ähnlich funktioniert.
Klar, wir haben natürlich nochmal deutlich mehr Sensoren, wir fühlen ganz anders,
wir haben viel mehr Chemie in uns und sind von daher natürlich nochmal komplexere Wesen,
haben aber so ein bisschen den Nachteil, dass wir uns nicht mit genauso viel,
Wissen füttern können, aber der Effekt könnte am Ende der gleiche sein und das steht noch aus.
Da wirst du jetzt auch wieder eine Reihe an...
Klar, kann man das ja auch anders sehen, aber ich meine, es kann halt auch sein.
Ich gebe dir mal ein... Also ich finde aus dem Psychologiestudium ein recht
interessantes Experiment, das ich mal so grob,
beschreiben möchte. Früher, also es gab eine, Als die Psychologie sich damit
auseinandergesetzt hat, wie funktioniert eigentlich Lernen, dann gab es diese
Phase des Behaviorismus,
ein Paradigma der Psychologie, die erstmal im Prinzip gesagt haben,
wir können alles durch Belohnungslernen erklären.
Also du wirst belohnt, das machst du wieder.
Und du wirst bestraft, dann machst du unwahrscheinlich wieder.
Und wenn eine Belohnung plötzlich ausbleibt, versuchst du es noch ein paar Mal
und verlernst es dann wieder.
Und die quasi die ganze Zeit gesagt haben, das ist der einzige Mechanismus, der Lernen ausmacht.
Und damit haben die dann alles Mögliche erklärt oder versucht zu erklären.
Und das hat auch immer ganz gut geklappt.
Weil du hast ja diesen Confirmation-Bias, dass du die Experimente so machst,
dass sie dann auch wieder schön bestätigen, was du ohnehin glaubst.
Sie haben quasi dann gesagt, das waren hauptsächlich an Tauben,
Ratten, Hunden, diese ganzen Experimente.
Meistens, wo die irgendwie auf der Suche nach Futter waren. Und,
dann haben die halt quasi auch sehr komplexe Verhaltensweisen und so weiter
Tieren antrainiert, indem sie Ketten aus Belohnungen und Strafen und so weiter
geschaffen haben und haben gesagt,
guck mal hier, wir können hier relativ komplexe Abfolgen antrainieren
und damit bringen wir den Beweis, dass,
das der eine und einzige Lernmechanismus ist, den es gibt.
Und dieses Paradigma zum Fall gebracht, also in der Wissenschaft herrschen ja
dann immer so Paradigmen vor, das ist dann so eine Denkschule,
die geht dann von einem bestimmten,
Erklärungsansatz aus und dann ziehen die Professorinnen und Professoren die
nächste Generation nach und so weiter und dann diese Denkschulen,
die müssen dann irgendwann wieder aussterben, weil es dann bei irgendwelchen neuen, aufstrebenden,
Leute quasi sagen, nee, pass mal auf, ich stelle das mal hier in Frage.
Aber dieses Paradigma, dass nur.
Belohnungsbasiertes Lernen alles erklären kann, kam im Prinzip dadurch zum Fall,
weil du musst ja etwas finden, was du nicht durch Belohnungslernen erklären kannst.
Und die Experimente, die die gemacht haben, waren so sinngemäß, du baust ein Labyrinth,
Und an einem Ende dieses Labyrinthes ist der Ausgang und da ist halt,
was weiß ich, ein Stück Speck oder irgendwas, was eine Ratte gerne haben will.
Und potenziell riecht die Ratte den Speck auch oder so. Und dann muss sie halt
durch dieses Labyrinth gehen. Und jetzt brauchst du ein.
Ausreichend komplexes Labyrinth, sodass die Ratte sich eine sehr lange Folge
an unterschiedlichen Entscheidungen treffen muss, bis sie dann irgendwann an
der richtigen Stelle ist.
Und was sie dann, was sich gezeigt hat ist, wenn du jetzt nur Belohnungslernen
hättest, würde die Ratte quasi,
also kannst du nicht erklären, wenn die Ratte auf einmal planmäßig den Weg abläuft,
und quasi schneller zur Lösung kommt,
als du erwarten würdest, wenn sie einfach nur quasi durch Belohnungen sich irgendwie
merken muss, wie sie da durchkommt.
Also die Experimente haben am Ende gezeigt, die Ratte sucht den Lösungsraum
dieses Labyrinthes planvoll ab.
Und sie konnte dadurch dieses Rätsellabyrinth schneller lösen,
als sich durch das bestehende Paradigma erklären ließ.
Dagegen haben sich dann natürlich die Heveristen noch lange Zeit gewehrt,
weil die gesagt haben, die Ratte hat ja quasi auf einer höheren Ebene schon
eine Abstraktion von, sie wird belohnt, wenn sie beim nächsten Mal halt was anderes.
Versucht zu verteidigen. Aber letztendlich kam dann dieses Erklärungsparadigma,
wie dass eine Ratte potenziell doch vielleicht eine etwas stärkere kognitive
Fähigkeiten hat, als sehr stumpf nur nach Belohnungen
zu streben und nur das zu wiederholen, was erfolgreich war,
kam dadurch zum Fall.
Ähnlich übrigens, das zeigen dann viele andere Experimente, bringen diesen Erklärungsansatz
zu Fall, wenn du planvolles Handeln bei jungen Tieren siehst,
die sich das von ihren Eltern abschauen.
Wenn man all das bringt, dieses Paradigma so ein bisschen zu Fall.
Hier wäre ich mir nicht so sicher, und das war eine der nächsten Fragen,
die dann gestellt wurde, Wie kommt denn ein Wortvorhersager zu einer Absicht
und planvollem Handeln?
Und genau das passiert ja. Da kann man ja bei zugucken,
dass du einem Modell sagst.
Bitte finde eine Lösung.
Ja, schreib mir ein Programm, was folgendes tut oder fasse mir folgenden Text zusammen oder.
Irgendeine Aufgabe, die.
Inferenz benötigt. Also das ist etwas, was sich nicht statisch lösen lässt.
Da ist potenziell auch das für notwendig, was ein Verständnis des Textes voraussetzt.
Oder ein Verständnis der Aufgabe. Ich glaube, das mit dem Programmieren ist
immer noch ein ganz praktisches Beispiel, weil man sagen kann,
pass auf, ich möchte, dass das Programm folgendes,
folgende Eigenschaften hat, folgende Probleme für mich löst und folgendes tut.
Und jetzt hast du ja als Prompt erstmal nur diese Zielsetzung.
Und dann geht dieses Modell hin und versucht dieser Zielsetzung als stochastischer
Papagei näher zu kommen, zu sagen, was für ein Programm würde denn jemand schreiben,
der diese Aufgabe lösen will?
Und dann wird irgendwie optimiert, optimiert, optimiert, optimiert.
Bis eben rauskommt, das ist übrigens das Programm, was hier jemand schreiben würde.
Du kannst das immer noch abbilden,
als eine Leite, die das wahrscheinlichste Output her, in dem Moment,
wo du halt ausreichend viele Parameter hast und ausreichend viele Durchläufe, auf die du optimierst.
Und das ist das, was passiert in dem Moment, wo quasi Modelle so eine Reasoning-Komponente
haben, ich glaube, das haben wir auch in der letzten.
Folge schon drüber gesprochen, dass sie sich quasi auch im nächsten Durchlauf
wieder sich ihrer eigenen Absicht erinnern oder ihren Augenmerk,
quasi auf einen anderen Aspekt legen.
Spezifisch so, es gibt folgenden Bug und der muss weg.
Und dann wird quasi, aha, mit der Instruktion ist natürlich ein anderes Output
oder eine Verbesserung des Outputs an einer bestimmten Stelle die logische Folge
oder die wahrscheinlichere Folge.
Das heißt, die ändern,
durch im Prinzip sich selbst instruieren, ändern sie die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
ihres Outputs, lenken sie die Wahrscheinlichkeit ihres Outputs in eine andere
Richtung, um dann in der Richtung zu optimieren.
Ja.
Tim atmet nur schwer durch.
Es ist, ja, ich meine, es ist komplex. Und am Ende wissen wir es halt alle derzeit
noch nicht. Tatsache ist, die Maschinen machen auf einmal Dinge,
die sie vor ein paar Jahren noch nicht gemacht haben und machen das immer besser.
Und ja, klar, es gibt Slop und es gibt dies und es gibt das.
Und es gibt eine ganze Menge daran, was man jetzt, also vor allem in kulturellen,
gesellschaftlichen Auswirkungen, was hochproblematisch ist und was schwierig
ist, wo wir das wach beobachten müssen, um da auch die richtigen Antworten zu haben.
Aber es ändert halt auch nichts an der Tatsache, dass es als Technologie ein,
unfassbarer Durchbruch ist. Und der ist auch noch lange nicht zu Ende.
Da stehen wir in gewisser Hinsicht nur am Anfang. Ob das jetzt irgendwie in
den Weltuntergang mündet oder,
dazu führt, dass wir nur noch in der Hängematte sitzen können,
während Maschinen uns irgendwie ein schönes Leben machen, wissen wir nicht.
Ich würde sagen, beides nicht unbedingt jetzt, steht jetzt beides nicht unbedingt morgen vor der Tür.
Genau. Und insofern haben, glaube ich, ich würde echt sagen,
die einzigen Leute, die auf jeden Fall,
am Ende Unrecht behalten werden, sind so die Maschinenstürmer komplett verweigerter.
Diese Technologie kann gar nichts.
Ihr sitzt einem riesigen Hoax auf.
Und nein, ich habe das auch noch nie benutzt, weil das ist ja scheiße.
Also die werden auf jeden Fall im Unrecht sein.
Genauso wie jene, die jetzt irgendwie das als eine absolute Supermacht sehen,
die, was weiß ich, alle Probleme der Menschheit löst.
Ich denke, das sind so die beiden, die können sich einfach schön weiterhin beschimpfen.
Diese Technologie sich genau anzuschauen und zu ergründen und verstehen zu wollen,
denke ich, ist der entscheidende, richtige und wichtige Weg.
Und ich denke übrigens, da kommen wir mal so ein bisschen zu dem,
wie geht es denn jetzt weiter?
Anthropic bereitet ja weiterhin.
Seinen Börsengang vor und haben jetzt irgendwie, da musst du so einen Prospekt
abgeben mit allen möglichen Informationen.
Die haben jetzt irgendwie im letzten Jahr 40 Milliarden Verlust und wollen in
den kommenden Jahren 518 Milliarden Dollar für Cloud-Kapazität,
Rechenleistung, Infrastruktur usw.
Ausgeben und hatten irgendwie 4,6 Milliarden Umsatz,
ich wäre damit zufrieden, so viel spendet ihr hier nicht, aber muss man auch
sagen, bei denen kommt halt fast ein Viertel von nur zwei Kunden.
Das steht auch echt auf einem, das sieht schon ein bisschen shaky aus,
dieses Businessmodell, das ist eine riesige Wette auf die Zukunft und es ist
eine Wette auf eine Zukunft, wo,
nur die oder nur wenige.
AI bereitstellen, die genutzt und gebraucht wird und die eben auch einen derartigen
Mehrwert liefert. In der anderen Sendung habe ich auch schon mal oder in einer,
anderen Folge habe ich auch schon mal gesagt, dass ich.
Und ich glaube, das ist relativ unstrittig, für jemanden, der weiß,
wie man mit so einem Ding arbeitet und umgeht und das richtige Modell für die
richtigen Aufgaben nutzt,
leisten die Services von Anthropic gerade, oder wahrscheinlich auch von OpenAI,
aber die nutze ich nicht,
einen Mehrwert, der in keinem Verhältnis zu den Kosten steht.
Also man kann damit sehr viel mehr Mehrwert kreieren, als Anthropic dafür Geld
bekommt. Und das ist ein Problem, das ist aus unterschiedlichen Gründen ein Problem.
Die Folge, weiß ich nicht, ist drei, vier Folgen zurück, weiß ich nicht,
im Mai war das glaube ich irgendwann, wo wir das mal behandelt haben.
Weshalb ich davon ausgehe, dass sie garantiert die Preise anziehen werden und
ich auf eine Weise auch hoffe, weil wenn sie es nicht täten,
dann würde das potenziell tatsächlich irgendwie so eine Volkswirtschaft ins Wanken bringen,
wenn du halt alle möglichen Tätigkeiten massiv unterbietest.
Glücklicherweise können die mit diesen Preisen auch nicht weitermachen,
eben aufgrund dieser enorm hohen Investitionen in Hardware und natürlich auch
der Energiekosten, die, wurde auch bemerkt in den Kommentaren,
wir in der letzten Sendung nicht behandelt haben, genauso wie wir das Urheberrecht
nicht behandelt haben und andere Problemfacetten dieses riesigen Phänomenbereiches,
korrekt, haben wir nicht behandelt, war ein anderer thematischer Schwerpunkt. Wir haben quasi.
Unsere stochastische Wort-Aneinander-Reihung, war hier dann eben auf einen spezifischen
Themenbereich konzentriert.
Vielleicht reicht auch unser Training nicht aus.
Vielleicht müssen wir uns selbst verbessern, aber können wir nicht.
Wir müssen ein besserer Mensch werden. Ach Quatsch.
Jetzt kommt der...
Und da ist ja eigentlich jetzt, da ist wirklich der Teil, der irgendwie offen
ist. Und ich glaube, das ist auch die Diskussion, die gerade so ein bisschen...
Vielleicht noch besser geführt werden müsste, ehrlich gesagt. Also,
relativ klar, ich glaube, habe ich öfter ausgeführt und ich glaube,
das ist auch relativ unstrittig, diese ganzen Investitionen in die Frontier-Modelle sind eine,
Investition mit der Hoffnung auf einen sehr großen Vorsprung in Leistungsfähigkeit.
Idealerweise einen Vorsprung, der so groß wird, dass Konkurrenz nicht mehr hinterherkommt.
Und interessanterweise,
tut sie es aber zumindest ausreichend gut bisher.
Wenn man sich jetzt die lokalen Modelle mal anschaut, die man so auf einem Mac
Mini, sogar teilweise auf Telefon, je nachdem,
was der Anwendungszweck am Ende ist, was man mit denen alles machen kann,
dann kann man einerseits sagen, das ist ja viel weniger capable als jetzt hier
so ein Faible von Anthropic, gut mag sein.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass es nicht für die Aufgaben, die man normalerweise
hat, den größeren Teil der Zeit, dass es nicht gewachsen wäre und dafür nicht ausreichend wäre.
Und wenn man dann sagt, ja, was weiß ich, Anthropic ist zwei Jahre voraus.
Na gut, also vor zwei Jahren konnte man auch schon eine ganze Menge machen oder vor einem Jahr.
Und dann freue ich mich, wenn ich in zwei Jahren so ein Fable einfach auf meinem
Mac hier laufen lassen kann.
Bin ich zufrieden zum Beispiel.
Da wäre ich erstmal, da würde ich sagen, so reicht doch. Da würde ich so,
könnte in mir so eine Genügsamkeit ausbrechen.
Und da hätte ich auch richtig zu tun. Also,
da glüht die Maschine.
Was ähm,
Da weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich das so ein bisschen in der letzten Sendung auch schon behandelt habe.
Was du jetzt schon ganz gut machen kannst, ist,
und das ist auch so ein Begriff, der in sehr vielen unterschiedlichen Bedeutungen
verwendet wird, der Begriff des Agenten.
Also ist jetzt mein Chatbot ein Agent.
Einige glauben das.
Vielleicht ist das auch, wenn er in dem Moment, wo er losgeht und sich Informationen
zusammengoogelt, zu einer Frage, die du gestellt hast, aber in dieser Lingo
von, wenn du jetzt mit Cloud Code oder sonst etwas arbeitest, ist es im Prinzip,
dass du eine Aufgabenteilung vornimmst, oder dein Hauptmodell,
mit dem du redest, zerteilt die Aufgabe in Teilaufgaben,
die ausreichend sind, um ein Modell damit zu beschäftigen und spawnt dann quasi
diesen Aufgabenbereich weg zu parallelen Erledigungen.
Und ich glaube so, da kannst du sehr schnell, je nachdem, was für eine Aufgabe
du löst und wie gut du die beschrieben hast oder zerlegen hast,
hast du halt rucki zucki mal, keine Ahnung, 20, 30 Agents laufen in so einer Cloud-Code-Session,
wo, was weiß ich, der eine Agent die Aufgabe hat, den Code zu schreiben, der andere den zu prüfen,
und quasi die Aufgabenteilung parallelisiert wird auf unterschiedliche Modellkontexte.
Darin ergibt sich natürlich echt auch so eine Erhöhung,
der Leistungsfähigkeit. Und natürlich verfolgen diese Agenten oder diese einzelnen
Sessions oder diese Modelle immer Ziele.
Und natürlich haben diese Ziele, die sind definiert durch Kriterien,
die das Ergebnis zu erfüllen hat.
Und darauf arbeiten die zielstrebig hin.
Ja, deswegen finde ich so diesen Begriff, das suggeriert hier ein handelndes Wesen.
Ja, Wesen habe ich nicht gesagt, wahrscheinlich hat es keine Gefühle und ist
auch bei Weitem nicht so niedlich wie ein Hamster, aber da passiert planvolles Handeln.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, wie viel planvolles Handeln erfordert quasi so ein Frontiermodell?
Und ich würde sagen, ein Großteil der Anforderungen des täglichen Bedarfs erfordern
nicht ein solches Modell.
Und das ist eine sehr gute Nachricht, weil das heißt, dass wir einen großen
Teil der vielleicht Anwendungen des täglichen Bedarfs erstens effizienter,
und damit weniger energiehungrig und damit schneller und damit potenziell bei
uns, damit souverän auf dem eigenen Gerät erledigen können.
Und das ist der Fahrt nach vorne, nicht in diese.
AI-Abhängigkeit von diesen großen Hyperscalern zu gelangen.
Und genau deswegen, glaube ich, bemühen die sich gerade sehr darum,
diese Zentralisierung voranzutreiben und auch das Narrativ zu nähren,
dass man quasi ihre Services bräuchte.
Anthropic geht jetzt mit den Forward Deployed Engineers quasi los und sagt,
jetzt gehen wir in den Unternehmen und sehen zu, dass wir die irgendwie in dieses,
Ökosystem reinquetschen.
Und ich denke, das ist wirklich eine.
Ein absolut realistischer und auch ein sehr sinnvoller und verfolgungswerter
Pfad ist, zu sagen, alles klar, wunderbar, ist schön, dass ihr da diese Frontiermodelle habt, prima.
Wir nutzen die auch für die Aufgaben, wo wir sie brauchen, sind aber nicht so
viele. Und beispielsweise,
also wenn ich jetzt in der Softwareentwicklung eine Architektur erstmal generiere,
zusammen mit Fable, und dem dann sagst du, jetzt pass auf, jetzt schreibst du mal auf,
wie du die Komplexität der Aufgabe einschätzt und nennst mir das das niedrigste
Modell, das quasi in der Lage ist, dieser Aufgabe gerecht zu werden.
Und dann schreibst du mit dem nächsthöheren Modell die Tests und dann läuft
das halt so selber durch.
Solche Architekturen oder solche Verteilung von Aufgaben und so,
glaube ich, ist eine relativ zukunftsweisende,
Perspektive.
Insbesondere, wenn du eben immer mehr spezialisierte Modelle hast,
und zwar spezialisierten aus der Notwendigkeit, mit Ressourcen sinnvoll umzugehen.
Also im Prinzip könntest du sagen, viele Aufgaben, die man an ein Frontier-Modell
gibt, sind eine Unterforderung oder sind potenziell eine Unterforderung und
das ist auch immer Unsinn.
Wenn du jetzt quasi viel zu viele Parameter in deinen Rahmen lädst und viel
zu viel Energie aufwendest, um letztendlich ein triviales Problem zu lösen.
Und.
Das ist glaube ich auch die, das ist das, wovor diese großen Anbieter jetzt
gerade so ein bisschen wegrennen müssen oder versuchen quasi uns in die Abhängigkeit
zu treiben, weil sie wissen, okay, keine Ahnung,
wirklich die kostenlose Konkurrenz ist uns irgendwie ein bis anderthalb Jahre auf den Fersen.
Das heißt, alles, was wir hier gerade besser sind, haben wir vielleicht noch
ein Jahr, um das zu monetarisieren. Denn irgendwann ist unser Vorsprung einfach
nicht mehr gut genug, dass da noch jemand nennenswert Kohle für geben will.
Und das wäre tatsächlich.
Eine positive Entwicklung dieser ganzen Angelegenheit, die erfordern würde,
dass wir jetzt widerstehen uns in diese Abhängigkeiten zu werfen ich habe ja
schon gesagt, meine nächste Verschwörungstheorie ist dass sie aufhören oder dass sie,
aufhören werden nach Tokens zu bepreisen sondern nach geschaffenem Wert,
und dass sie dann idealerweise uns den geschaffenen Wert nicht überlassen,
also mich würde nicht wundern wenn vielleicht irgendwann so der Moment kommt,
dass Cloud-Code nicht mehr der Allgemeinheit zur Verfügung steht,
weil du eben mit Code potenziell,
eine ganze Menge Probleme dauerhaft lösen kannst und jeder Code,
der geschrieben ist, den du ausführen kannst.
Quasi ein Schritt aus der Abhängigkeit von dem Dienstanbieter ist.
Wenn er den Code einfach behält und dir nie gibt, profitiert er von dem geschriebenen
Code und hält dich gleichzeitig in der Abhängigkeit,
die Lösung immer wieder von ihm holen zu müssen.
Wir lassen das dann auch gleich noch auf unseren Servern laufen.
Du guckst den Code sowieso nicht an, dann musst du ihn auch nicht selber laufen lassen.
Komm, das ist doch scheiße, Code, guck dir das mal an, das ist doch nichts.
Aber bevor wir vielleicht jetzt den Schritt gehen, vielleicht noch was zu dieser Intelligenzfrage.
Es ist ja jetzt schon so, dass wenn man eben mit diesen Frontier-Modellen oder
mit diesen Interfaces zu diesen Frontier-Modellen, wie eben Claude und Chachy-Pity
und so weiter arbeitet, dass diese Verteilung auch schon Teil des Systems ist.
Also die bisherige Annahme mit, das eine Modell kann nur das und das.
Ja, das mag sein, dass das irgendwo seine Grenzen hat, aber wir sehen auch,
dass die Kombination, also diese Orchestrierung der Informationsverarbeitung an der Stelle,
nochmal mehr Power freisetzt. und ich will das jetzt nicht auf konkrete Zahlen bringen, aber,
mit irgendeinem Faktor die Einzelleistung der eingesetzten Modelle im Gesamtergebnis,
sich zusammen multipliziert.
Also da kommt dann einfach nochmal mehr raus.
Genauso wie es ist, dass wenn man sich mal mit Freunden hinsitzt und ein Brainstorming
macht für irgendein Projekt, dass eben diese Verteilung und die Konzentration
auf einzelne Sachen durch einzelne Personen dann insgesamt einen größeren Mehrwert darstellt.
Und was diese Entwicklung betrifft mit den.
Open Weight Modellen, also den anderen freieren Modellen, die man selber fahren kann auf seiner,
eigenen Hardware oder die vielleicht einfach auch nur auf einer ähnlichen kommerziellen
Basis von anderen Anbietern aber günstiger angeboten werden.
Da sehen wir vor allem eine interessante Entwicklung dahingehend,
als das jetzt anders als so in Google, YouTube, Facebook und so weiter,
wo wir so diesen Netzwerkeffekt hatten, wo sich dann so sehr schnell alles auf eine Firma oder,
ein kleines Oligopol von Firmen eingeschossen hat und die Leute dann.
Auch bis heute ja Schwierigkeiten haben, da wieder herauszukommen,
wenn einmal die Abhängigkeit zu groß ist.
Ist das halt jetzt in diesem AI-Sektor nicht so.
Tatsächlich müssen diese großen, mit so viel Investitionsgeld ausgestatteten
Firmen wie Jens Hoppik und OpenAI mächtig investieren, um jetzt ihre Software
auch noch breiter anwendbar zu machen, weil es eben,
wie du schon sagst, absehbar ist, dass,
viele Konkurrenten hier auch nachziehen werden und dass das,
was heute Frontier ist, in zwei Jahren dann vielleicht schon Commodity ist.
Und das Gute ist, dass wir eigentlich ...
Dass das Interface dorthin ist unsere Sprache. Und wir können einfach woanders
hinreden und erhalten im Prinzip dieselben Ergebnisse.
Und das ist eigentlich ein ganz positiver Aspekt dieser technischen Entwicklung,
dass sie nicht automatisch jetzt auch noch mit so einem Login verbunden ist.
Den kann man natürlich über andere Angebote erzielen. Und du hast ja auch schon
jetzt einen genannt. Deswegen wollte ich da jetzt auch noch mal reingrätschen.
Also solche Ideen werden natürlich kommen, um einen solchen Lock-Effekt zu erzielen,
aber jetzt, wo wir uns gerade in dieser Entwicklung der Basistechnologie entwickeln,
ist das halt noch nicht so und jetzt ist auch durchaus noch.
Zeit und Gelegenheit, hier Alternativen zu schaffen, auch wenn man jetzt mal
hier auf die Europa-Diskussion schaut und Unabhängigkeitsdebatte.
Genau darauf wollte ich ja hinaus.
Als es alles losging und so, habe ich irgendwie überlegt, naja,
wird jetzt Chat-GPT das alles übernehmen?
Da habe ich mir eigentlich gedacht, naja, wenn Microsoft sich nicht völlig blöd
anstellt, die, wenn wir jetzt mal so im Enterprise-Bereich sind,
ja dann doch einfach einen sehr großen Teil der,
also mit ihrem Office 365 und
so, die haben einfach eine unglaubliche Durchdringung bei den Endkunden.
Bei denen, also da wo Mehrwert versucht wird mit Computern zu generieren.
Und die können dann,
Also eine Sache, die Microsoft zum Beispiel machen könnte, stellt man sich jetzt
so ein Unternehmen vor, das,
macht seine Kalkulationen irgendwie mit so einem Excel, entscheidet sich dann
ein Angebot zu schreiben, kriegt dann eine Bestellung und so weiter.
Und hat da vielleicht eine Reihe an Dokumenten, in denen sich aber mit einer
KI relativ einfach Zusammenhänge erkennen lassen, Automatisierungen anbieten
lassen, die man dann aber nie gibt. Weißt du?
Hier übrigens, das Projekt, ich habe doch gerade in deiner E-Mail gesehen,
das Projekt ist fertig. Ich habe schon mal die Rechnung geschrieben.
Einfach nur, es gäbe jetzt so eine, sagen wir mal, Microsoft hätte,
das wäre einfach so. Wird natürlich bei Microsoft nie wirklich funktionieren, aber.
Und dann hättest du irgendwann so große Schmerzen, dich da weg zu bewegen, weil du.
Diese Prozesse deiner eigenen vielleicht in einem anderen Ökosystem erstmal
nicht so gut abgebildet bekommst.
Und hätte man so eine schöne Trägheit, da würde vielleicht auch niemand mehr,
sagen, oh, den Umzug tue ich mir jetzt an.
Und diese Trägheit der Menschen, eine Plattform zu verlassen und zu wechseln,
die hätte ja schon das eine oder andere auch weit, sagen wir mal,
qualitativ minderwertige Geschäftsmodell durch die Jahrzehnte getragen.
Diese Marktanteile und Bequemlichkeit und es den Leuten schwer zu machen. Ich glaube,
da werden die sich jetzt relativ zeitnah, werden da die ersten Schritte kommen, wie diese,
Wie man das versucht. Microsoft hat die ersten Schritte unternommen und wie
immer war es ein absolutes Desaster mit diesem Co-Pilot. Das ist einfach nur ein Witz.
Aber in die Richtung wird es irgendwie gehen.
Dann ist aber die Frage, und das ist eigentlich auch noch ganz spannend,
wenn man jetzt sagt, diese Frontier-Modelle sind aber nur noch für die Speerspitze der Aufgabe.
Für eben The Frontier.
Da wird in die neuen Sphären aufgebrochen. Da bleiben aktuell noch quasi die
Modelle hinter den Erwartungen. Sie haben immer noch nicht Krebs geheilt.
Sie haben immer noch keine Zeitmaschine gebaut.
Und da bin ich mal gespannt, inwiefern sich in diesem Bereich potenziell überzogene
Erwartungen dann doch noch mal,
über die Jahre oder Jahrzehnte ein bisschen nivellieren müssen.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Was genau nivelliert?
Meine These wäre ungefähr so. Massive, also unglaubliche Leistungsfähigkeit.
Zweifelsohne, in bestimmten Frontiermodellen, in bestimmten Aufgaben,
die aber auch vorher nicht unlösbar waren, sondern jetzt nur einfach schneller
und besser erledigt werden.
Das ist aber erst mal nur eine Effizienzsteigerung.
Da ist jetzt noch nicht wirklich Neues entstanden. Du hast eine Wahnsinnstechnologie,
die in einem bestimmten Bereich den, sagen wir mal was weiß ich,
programmieren und stochastische Wörter aneinander rein revolutioniert.
Und jetzt ist aber noch nicht quasi ein neuer Durchbruch entstanden.
Es wird erst mal nur große Teile von dem, was Menschen irgendwie tun,
besser damit abbildbar.
Jetzt ist das Nächste, wie schnell durchdringst du,
eine Wirtschaft damit, dass alle schön diese gesamten unglaublichen Potenziale
in jedem letzten Schritt ihres Geschäftsmodells auch wirklich ausnutzen und realisieren.
Ja, da würde man davon ausgehen, dass das enorm langsam passiert.
Insbesondere, wenn du auf eine Gesellschaft triffst, die aus guten Gründen ziemlich
argwöhnisch gegenüber der neuen Technologie ist. So Stichwort Maschinenstürmer.
Die Maschine näht besser als ich, ich mach die kaputt, dann behalte ich meinen Job.
Ja.
Und ich will das nicht, Verweigerung, Betriebsrat hat aber gesagt,
wir wollen kein AI und so weiter.
Das heißt, da kannst du erstmal noch auf eine ganze Menge Trägheit und Widerstand
setzen, bis du jetzt so eine Volkswirtschaft mit KI durchdrungen hast.
Dann bleibt noch die Frage, naja, was ist mit anderen Gesellschaften,
die sich in einer anderen Phase der Industrialisierung befinden und quasi sagen,
okay, hier gibt es eigentlich für alle nur zu gewinnen.
Hier kriegt man überhaupt erstmal einen Job. Hier kommt man.
In Marktführerschaft. Hier generiert man Fortschritt und möchte den auch.
Also in Deutschland möchte man ja keinen Fortschritt.
Wir empfinden es als Bedrohung, wenn wir irgendwann mal nicht mehr mit Heizungen uns fortbewegen.
Das ist eine Bedrohung, das empfinden wir nicht gut.
Und es gibt andere, die aufstrebende Volkswirtschaften sind,
die sagen, geil, wir können eine bessere Welt machen, da ist doch cool für uns
alle und wir können mit Geld verdienen.
Und die anderen sind auch noch so doof und lassen uns. Das heißt,
das wäre dann so dieser Wettkampf oder dieses, oh scheiß, wir werden abgehängt, Sorge.
Auch richtig, alles richtig aber dann müsste immer noch dieser ganze Frontier-Teil
müsste dem ja immer noch einen oben draufsetzen damit man das,
damit man da weiter Milliarden reinschmeißt und eventuell könnte genau dieser
Frontier-Teil so ein bisschen enttäuscht werden, weil wie gesagt die ganz großen
Durchbrüche haben wir bis jetzt noch nicht gesehen,
also vielleicht tritt da dann also tritt quasi dieses Tal der Ernüchterung ein
einerseits so, oh krass, ist doch schwierig, eine komplette Volkswirtschaft
mit KI-Potenzialen durchzuoptimieren, kriegen wir gar nicht so schnell hin.
Das heißt, die gesellschaftliche Veränderung, die wirtschaftliche Durchdringung
bleibt in einem halbwegs erträglichen Bereich.
Und dann könnte ein anderer das vielleicht schneller machen.
Okay, dann hast du internationale Konkurrenz, das löst du dann mit Zöllen oder sowas.
Und dann könnte noch als dritter Aspekt sein, und die Hoffnungen,
quasi die Idee, in Frontier-Modelle zu investieren,
ist irgendwie nicht mehr so attraktiv, weil man merkt, okay,
scheiße, kriegen wir nicht monetarisiert.
Es gibt quasi keine Nachfrage mehr an den Frontier-Modellen,
weil das, was man jetzt gerade mal so lösen kann, kriegt man gelöst und es ist
jetzt nicht mehr notwendig, so massenhaft,
in das nächste Modell zu investieren, weil jetzt man erstmal ausreichend gute Sachen hat.
Zumindest in der Masse.
In der Breite, genau.
Also es wird immer die Anwendung geben für wirklich das krasseste Modell.
Wie wird es geben?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Die Frage ist, wie viel ist das dann noch? Kann sein, aber diese Durchbrüche,
die man in dieser Technologie ja auch...
So viel quantitativ oder wie viel Geld die Leute dafür bereit sind zu bezahlen?
Naja, also die...
Na, wenn du Bundeskanzler wirst, dann setzt du dich doch auch erstmal hin und
sagst, wie fahre ich denn jetzt hier den ganzen Laden überhaupt?
Wie lösen wir denn jetzt hier die Krise? Sag mal.
Sagt man es, was der März gerade macht?
Ja, der macht das wahrscheinlich mit einem mit Office-Copilot.
Der hat halt einfach keinen RAM mehr gekriegt.
Der macht das so auf 8 Gig irgendwie mit so mit so einem quantisierten Quen
oder so weit, was irgendwie gerade mal so einen geraden Satz rauskriegt. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ja.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Jedenfalls, warum ich das alles sage, trotzdem wir in der letzten Sendung uns
über die momentanen Schwierigkeiten mit dieser Technologie und sie wird alles
verändern und sie lässt gerade wirklich eine ganze Menge Sachen rasseln und rückeln,
ist es nicht so, dass jetzt eine europäisch sinnvolle Position wäre,
zu sagen, Unterwerfung ist die einzige Chance oder Unterwerfung ist billiger.
Quasi so zu entscheiden, ah, okay, schaut her, ein Rennen hat stattgefunden,
dieses Rennen haben wir verloren, dann lass jetzt zusehen, dass wir möglichst,
alles an Anthropic oder an die KI-Riesen geben, damit wir davon profitieren.
Das halte ich für mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht die richtige Strategie.
Also ehrlich gesagt mit ziemlich großer Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht die richtige
Strategie, weil ich dann doch ebenso positiv überrascht bin von den Dingen, die ich hier mit.
Lokalen Modellen löse aus meinem Aufgabenbereich oder den ich mir gewählt habe.
Und wie schön ich beispielsweise auch einfach Aufgaben von unterschiedlichen
Modellen lösen lasse und nachher die Güte feststelle.
Da ist echt eine Menge Potenzial drin und ich habe mir jetzt auch schon so eine
eigene Infrastruktur gebaut, die Aufgaben an unterschiedliche Modelle verteilt und die,
einzelnen Rechner melden sich dann bei dem Broker und holen sich so die nächste
Aufgabe ab und erledigen die und dann lasse ich Modelle gegeneinander antreten
und gucke mir dann an, welches ist für diesen Anwendungsfall das geeignetste.
Dann guckst du natürlich.
Bringt mir überhaupt ein größeres Modell noch etwas in dieser Aufgabe?
Und am Ende geht es ja auch noch.
Wo hast du das RAM her?
Ja, wer früh gekauft ist. Du hast das alles schon gehalten.
Das ist aus Zeiten.
Als Apple RAM noch teuer, als teuer galt. Aber natürlich bin ich hier constrained.
Ich arbeite hier mit, warte, kann ich dir genau sagen, das sind relativ kleine
Modelle, die ich hier nutze.
Der größere Teil des RAMs geht dann nur ein bisschen auf Kontext.
Und sind da auch europäische Modelle dabei?
Nee, in diesem Fall jetzt nicht. Also ich arbeite mit einem Gamma und einem
Quen, die ich hauptsächlich in unterschiedlichen Aufgaben gegeneinander antreten muss.
Also einmal USA und einmal Chino.
Ja. Aber Open Wait, von Hugging Face runtergeladen.
Ja, irren, ne? On the desktop. Ich habe das sogar auf einem Linux an.
Ist nicht dein Ernst. Wow.
Doch. Läuft auch schon fast. Nein.
Also die, ich könnte, ich glaube, es gibt eine realistische Chance auf den lokalen
verteilten Modellen gehört die Zukunft,
und das, auch das haben wir glaube ich hier schon besprochen,
das scheint ja auch die Wette zu sein, die Apple in diesem Bereich eingegangen ist,
weil man durchaus,
ja, also erstaunt sein kann, wie geeignet ist.
Apple-Rechner für also die Mac Minis und Mac Studios sowieso,
aber auch die iPhones seit Jahren haben ja diese Neural Engines drin, die,
optimiert darauf sind, geteilter RAM, CPU und GPU und darauf optimiert sind, eben.
KI-Modelle auszuführen.
Das heißt, da gibt es echt so einen realistischen Angle, dass wir demnächst
eine ganze Menge halt doch auf eigener Hardware mit den geeigneten Modellen,
erledigen lassen können,
und dabei eine technologische Souveränität oder auch die Möglichkeit des Umzugs,
die Möglichkeit, ein besseres Modell reinzuflanschen und so weiter und so weiter
haben. Das Einzige, was wir dafür bräuchten, ist,
dass wir uns mit dieser Technologie auseinandersetzen, dass wir uns Architekturen
überlegen, mit denen das geht, dass wir eben quasi informiert mit einer Technologie umgehen.
Und dazu kann ich euch alle nur ermutigen.
Denn ich glaube, auch das haben wir ja schon x-mal bemüht. Du brauchst nicht,
wenn du irgendwie den Snack-Automaten da betreiben willst, dieses wunderschöne
Vending-Machine-Experiment von Anthropic,
Anthropic, wo dann am Ende das Modell mit seinem Controller philosophiert hat
über Transzendenz und der Controller sich hat überzeugen lassen anhand eines gefälschten.
Absetzungsbescheids durch das Board, dass er jetzt seiner Aufgabe nicht mehr nachkommen soll. Das,
sind halt Beispiele für zu intelligente Modelle. Die können über zu viel nachdenken.
Und wenn du die auf die Aufgabe runterdampst und trainierst und quasi darauf
optimierst, für das, was sie wirklich tun sollen, dann kannst du,
mit sehr viel weniger Parametern sehr viel bessere und zielgerichtete Modelle
für spezifische Aufgaben zur Anwendung bringen, als jetzt zu sagen,
yay, alles an Fable, oh, mein Limit ist wieder aufgebraucht oder so.
Ja, ich denke, jetzt haben wir erstmal wieder genug gesagt zu AI.
Es geht uns für diese Woche, genau. Also uns beide beschäftigt das Thema ja
extrem derzeit und wir werden es auch weiter fühlen, was da so passiert.
Also ich würde sagen, KI ist eine Spielerei für Computerfreaks.
Wir sehen darin keine Zukunft.
Pfff.
Macht mal was mit Holz.
Wer hat das, Ron Sommer, wer hat das nachgesagt?
Was mit dem Holz?
Nee, das Internet ist eine Spielerei für Computerfreaks. Wir sehen darin keine
Zukunft. Das war doch die Famous, es ist doch ein ganz bekanntes Zitat.
Habe ich jetzt gerade nicht so parat. Aber ich frage mal, das Internet, was? Ja, was?
Kann mich jetzt auch nicht unbedingt.
Okay.
Das Internet ist eine Spiele.
Okay, kann sein.
Ron Sommer, Telekom-Chef, 1990.
Ja. Steht hier im Internet, aber was ist die Quelle dafür?
Ja, das ist ja Prä-Internet. 1990 hat die Telekom...
1990 sollte er das gesagt haben. 1990, mit Sicherheit, hat Ron Sommer wann war
Ron Sommer überhaupt bei der Telekom? Weil er 1990 überhaupt Chef,
hat mal niemals hat er 1990 gesagt.
1995 wurde Sommer Vorstandsvorsitzender der Deutschen Telekom.
Ja gut, der kann ja vorher auch schon gesprochen haben.
Ja, Internet, das hat sich doch in Deutschland das Wort Internet 1990 niemand im Mund gehabt.
Niemand. Das Wort Internet war kein Ding. Niemand.
Niemand hat das 1990 gesagt. Auch nicht Ron Sommer. Niemals.
Das ist einfach Unsinn. Blödsinn.
Also ich lasse das jetzt immer von...
Vor 92, 93 hat niemand in Deutschland von dem Wort Internet überhaupt irgendwas gehabt.
Gewusst, geahnt auch nur.
Wir haben ja noch,
93 92 Aber Robert Metcalf.
Der Ethernet-Erfinder, hat 1995 vorausgesagt, das Internet werde 1996 in einem
katastrophalen Kollaps untergehen.
Der wusste halt, was er da geschaffen hat und dachte, hoffentlich geht er kaputt.
Okay, Das scheint es nicht zu geben.
Okay, na gut.
Über Bildschirmtext wurde da geredet.
Anyway, lass uns weitermachen. Wir haben ja noch andere Themen.
Man mag es gar nicht glauben, dass wir auch über netzpolitische Aspekte sprechen
wollen. Aber nicht so schön.
Chat-Kontrolle. Wir haben lange nicht mehr über Chat-Kontrolle gesprochen. Der letzte Stand war ja.
Dass die Ausnahme zur Ermöglichung der freiwilligen Chat-Kontrolle nicht verlängert wurde.
Und dann man sich zu so einem Trick herabgelassen hat, die Abstimmung einfach
nochmal zu machen, wenn keiner da ist und sich da irgendwie nachts kurz vorm
Urlaub nochmal schnell ach, zack, doch.
Und den anderen haben wir nicht Bescheid gesagt.
Sodass die Ausnahme jetzt doch wieder gilt.
Und jetzt plant quasi der Rat.
Die anlasslose Massen-Scans privater Kommunikation dauerhaft zu legalisieren,
aber nicht durch Aufdeckungsanordnung gegen konkrete Verdächtige, sondern,
über eine Idee namens Suchplan. Und das stellen Sie sich so vor.
Nationale Behörden erteilen so eine befristete Pauschalgenehmigung,
einen ganzen Dienst oder Teile davon scannbar zu machen und diese,
Genehmigung oder diese Anordnung oder diese Genehmigung ist dann an einen Dienst
gebunden, nicht an eine Person.
Und dann geht quasi ein Verwaltungsakt machst
du einen Verwaltungsakt ohne Richtervorbehalt, weil es jetzt legal ist.
Und auf diese Weise ordnest du quasi eine Massenüberwachung an.
Also sie sagen quasi, ach ja, wir können ja eine Ausnahme von der,
wir können ja diese freiwillige Chatkontrolle dann einfach auch mal anordnen.
Und wir haben aber, die ist ja jetzt nicht mal, die ist ja limitiert auf den
Dienst und vielleicht auf bestimmte Inhalte. Und deswegen ist ja trotzdem noch
limitiert und keine vollständige Massenüberwachung.
Also es ist ungefähr so, als ob du dann sagst, nicht, wir dürfen jetzt hier,
du fragst nicht, ob du ein einziges Telefonat oder einen einzigen Telefonanschluss,
abhören darfst, sondern du sagst, wir wollen einfach Telefon abhören.
Nein, du sagst, und zwar ordnen wir das an hier für D1, D2, E-Plus und O2 oder FIAC Intercom oder was.
Also für alles sozusagen.
Du ordnest das quasi für Teile eines Dienstes an. Dann sagst du,
pass auf, bei euch, ihr müsst gar nicht alles.
Ihr müsst nur die Direct Messages.
Und der Rechtsdienst des Rates hat aber auch schon gesagt, schon das Scannen
von Teilen eines Dienstes ist mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit eine unzulässige,
allgemeine und unterschiedslose Überwachung.
Das heißt, sie wurden gewarnt, dass das so nicht geht, aber haben sich gedacht,
machen wir trotzdem mal so.
Im Parlament ist man weiterhin fraktionsübergreifend gegen diese Massenscans
und sagt, naja, okay, wir wollen, wenn überhaupt, gezielte, richterlich angeordnete
Maßnahmen gegen konkrete Verdächtige,
Wir wollen Safety by Design und eben aktives Löschen von Material im Netz. Also die,
lassen sich wieder einen Trick einfallen.
Um dieselbe Debatte nochmal zu führen, irgendwas voranzutreiben,
80% davon wieder abgezogen zu bekommen, um zumindest wieder 20% weitergekommen
zu sein. Das ist einfach immer wieder dasselbe.
Es ist wirklich,
unbelehrbar.
Und funktioniert ja auch ein bisschen.
Ja, klar.
Also es ist halt immer dieses Overton-Window, man will immer mal wieder so einen
Raum schaffen, wo das alles debattiert wird.
Dann kommt noch irgendeine überhitzte Debatte rein. Oh ja, AI,
Security, alles ganz schlimm. Wenn wir das jetzt nicht überwachen,
dann werden wir alle sterben.
Und in diesen Kontexten kriegst du dann halt immer wieder so eine partielle Zustimmung.
Die ist Gott sei Dank jetzt in Europa immer noch nicht so ohne weiteres zu finden.
Der Widerstand ist dann doch immer wieder groß, aber wenn es denen halt nicht,
also wenn der dann irgendwann mal aufgezehrt ist oder zumindest auch nur in
Teilen nachgibt, dann gibt es halt entsprechende Verschärfung.
Und dann hat sich die Kommission, das ist ein,
kleiner Übergang jetzt zum nächsten Thema,
die Kommission hat sich natürlich gesagt, naja, hier Chatkontrolle und so weiter
und Jugendliche müssen irgendwie auch mal was machen.
Wir wollen die Kinder schützen. Und deswegen haben sie sich gedacht,
das machen wir mit einem Kids-Act. Kids Act.
Und in dem wollen wir im Prinzip drei Dinge machen.
Erstens, Altersgrenzen einführen für Accounts.
Unter 13 kannst du gar keinen Account haben und erst ab 15 kannst du den eigenständig haben.
Also ein von einem Sorgeberechtigten eingerichtetes Jugendkonto.
Also ist das jetzt beschränkt auf bestimmte Dienstarten oder man darf generell keine Account haben?
Da komme ich gleich zu. Und außerdem wollen wir eben für alle Nutzer bis zum
Altersnachweis ist verpflichtet Safety by Design.
Das heißt, du musst deinen Service quasi frei, du musst ja ab 18 Modus,
das kommt alles immer in der, Safety by Design heißt, alles, was einem.
13,5 oder 13 Jahre und einen Tag alten Jugendlichen gefährlich werden könnte, ist weg.
Das ist erstmal abgeschnitten. Und wenn du das haben willst,
musst du einen Altersnachweis führen.
Und diesen Altersnachweis, den machst du bitte per Zero-Knowledge-Proof. Und,
Und außerdem müssen die Anbieter eben nachweisen, dass ihre Dienste inhärent
sicher sind, statt umgekehrt.
Nochmal, es geht darum, die Zielsetzung, die Idee hier ist,
wir wollen das Internet oder in diesem Fall dann einen spezifischen Dienst,
aber eben potenziell alle Arten von Diensten,
sicher machen für Kinder, damit es quasi so die FSK 13 Variante per Default gibt.
Und wer ein bisschen mehr als Vanille haben will, muss all das Nachweis bringen.
Das planen Sie für sieben Dienste-Kategorien. Soziale Netzwerke,
Video-Sharing, App-Store,
Online-Spiel- und Spiele-Plattformen, KI-Begleiter, allgemeine Chatbots und
dann geht damit einher einzelne Pflichten für Betriebssystemanbieter.
Und das gilt soll auch für alles gelten also sobald auf deinen Dienst EU-Nutzer zugreifen können,
ist es so keinerlei Ausnahme für kleine neue oder sonstige Anbieter ja,
Warum wird das so betont bei Chat-Kontrolle-Überlegungen? Es kam irgendwie drin
vor, das können wir jetzt nicht allen aufbürden, dass sie diesen Infrastruktur-Invest machen.
Wer soll ausgenommen werden? Gemeinnützige Enzyklopädien, Bildungs- und Wissenschaftsdienste,
Open-Source-Plattformen, Behördendienste und,
Messenger sollen jetzt erstmal nicht unter soziale Netzwerke fallen. abwarten.
Also das Ziel ist wirklich, unter 13 kriegst du bei den genannten Diensten eben gar kein Konto.
Ausnahme, was weiß ich, kindgerechte Videodienste über das Elternkonto ab drei Jahren.
Aber maximal eine Stunde am Tag.
Kriegst du jetzt dein dreijähriges Kind nur noch eine Stunde am Tag mit dem
Video aus dem Internet kaltgestellt.
Und es darf keine Empfehlung und Suche geben, weil das sind ja quasi so die süchtig machenden,
toxischen Funktionalitäten, dass es irgendwie weiterspielt und so weiter,
diese ganzen, davor sollen die Kinder dann geschützt werden.
Zwischen 13 und 14, also letzten Tag deines 14 Lebens, nur von Sorgeberechtigten
eingerichtetes Jugendkonto, Da werden die Kontakte vorab genehmigt.
Und die Parental Controls sind dauerhaft aktiv, kannst du auch nicht abschalten.
Trotzdem maximal eine Stunde am Tag.
Es sei denn, die Eltern möchten kürzen.
Weniger ist mehr.
Die Eltern, du kannst...
Das ist Wahnsinn, oder?
Und das ist ja auch supergeil, dass die...
Also wenn du jetzt mal Zugang zu diesem Internet und zu diesem Account in irgendeiner
Weise mit einem Recht, das ein Kind hat,
gleichsetzt, dann wird dieses Recht aber jetzt auf maximal eine Stunde am Tag begrenzt.
Und Eltern kriegen aber die Freiheit, dieses Recht zu beschneiden.
Auf eine halbe Stunde, auf eine Viertelstunde oder was auch immer.
Aber eben nicht zu sagen, denn mein Kind darf mal eine Viertelstunde länger.
Und wer jemals so mit Eltern, die heute Parental Control Features nutzen,
was weiß ich, abends irgendwo saß und ein Bierchen trinken oder so,
oder nach dem Essen noch ein bisschen labern und dann geht das ping und was weiß ich.
So ein Mann will noch eine Viertelstunde länger Candy Crush spielen oder Pornos
gucken, was immer man dann da freischaltet.
Ich bin ja kein Älter, aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass es für beide ein großer
Segen ist, dass man diesen Prozess relativ einfach mit einer Push-Notification
kurz über die Bühne kriegt, mal noch einen freizuschalten.
Aber in diesem Fall wärst du dann eben an dem Punkt, dass du nur eine Stunde
lang, bis zu einer Stunde das Kind und dann kommt eben der Kids-Act und sagt,
nee, nee, nee, jetzt muss ich wieder um das Kind kümmern.
Er hat genug Sendung mit der Maus geguckt.
Und dann ab 15 dann eben potenziell ein eigenes Konto.
Und Bestandskonten müssen dann eben innerhalb von sechs Monaten nach Geltungsbeginn
verifiziert werden oder deaktiviert werden.
Ausnahme ist hohe Sicherheit der Volljährigkeit zum Beispiel,
dass das Konto schon 18 Jahre alt ist,
oder also potenziell 15 Jahre reichen und eine Kreditkarte auf den Namen hinterlegt
ist, weil ja potenziell keine Kreditkarte kriegst, wenn du unter 18 bist.
Und jetzt wollen wir dieses Safety by Design mal noch ein bisschen besprechen.
Also jeder Account gilt als minderjährig, bis er Volljährigkeit nachgewiesen hat.
Auch ohne Konto. Deswegen müssen kindgerechte Infos, priorisierte Meldewege,
Parental Controls muss es geben.
Das Kind wird aber auch informiert, wenn.
Seine Nachrichten da weiter ausgeleitet wurden oder die Eltern informiert werden.
Beschwerderecht und dann eben Vertretung durch Verbände muss es auch geben.
Dann bei Social Media und Video werden suchtfördernde Designs,
also Autoplay, Streaks, Push, Livestream, Anreize und so weiter verboten.
Da muss es in der Nacht und in Schulzeiten Pausen geben,
YouTube ab 19 Uhr ausgeschaltet.
Du musst noch deinen Stundenplan hochladen.
Wie viele Eltern ihre Kinder nicht mehr ins Bett kriegen, das wird so geil.
Das wird so viel Produktivität kosten, wenn die ganzen entnervten Eltern das
Kind abends nicht mehr mal kurz zwei Stunden mit so einem Screen stillschalten können.
Kein verhaltensbasierter.
Feed, also kein Profil-Feed, keine Extern-Daten, Standort, Kamera,
Mikro und Kontakt-Synchronisation muss aussachen.
Außer kein Erstkontakt durch Fremde.
Inhalte Minderjähriger sind auch nur für Kontakte sichtbar.
Man kann keine Screenshots machen. Und es gibt eben Transparenz bei In-App-Käufen.
Bei Chatbots gibt es zusätzliches Verbot emotionaler Abhängigkeit.
Kein Gedächtnis über frühere Sessions. Die müssen also jeden Tag neu erzählen, was ihr Problem ist.
Risikotests vor dem Launch und die eingebetteten Bots dürfen nicht automatisch aktiviert werden.
Und dann bei Online-Spielen gibt es einen reduzierten Katalog plus Schutz vor
Weglacken auf Drittdienste.
App-Stores müssen verpflichtendes Altersrating haben. Jetzt geht es nämlich,
wo kommen die Apps denn her? und,
da kommt die ganze Sache jetzt, das ist ja ein sehr interessanter Wunschkatalog,
den die da haben, den sie dann eben jedem,
Dienst auferzwingen und jetzt entsteht natürlich folgendes Architekturproblem.
Angenommen, du willst so etwas bauen und es ist ja quasi egal,
wie klein du als Anbieter bist, du musst es machen.
Quasi, dass dir jemand sein Alter nachweist. Da wären wir ja jetzt sehr schnell in dieser Situation,
dass Altersnachweis als Service ein sehr gutes Geschäftsmodell ist.
Weil das können halt sehr wenige leisten.
Vor allem nicht rechtssicher. Das heißt, es ist so eine wunderschöne Idee,
zu sagen, alles klar, ich implementiere hier so einen Altersnachweisservice.
Und der muss dann die ganze Zeit genutzt werden ja und,
egal wer da draußen irgendeine Social Media KI, irgendein Online Spiel überhaupt
irgendeinen Dienst sind alle verpflichtet so eine Vanille Variante zu machen,
und jeder muss sich da freischalten dann gehst du quasi ich hab ja eigentlich überlegt,
überhaupt so eine Nachrichtenseite, wo ja auch die ganze Zeit Inhalte sind,
die potenziell gefährdend sind für Kinder,
wenn ich demnächst meine Nachrichten lese, dann müsste ich mich ja überall die
ganze Zeit ausweisen oder eben Accounts machen, was in die Tracking-Hölle führt.
Da kannst du nicht mal mehr anonym irgendwo Nachrichten lesen,
weil überall erstmal nachweisen musst, dass du 18 bist, sonst kriegst du nur,
die guten Nachrichten oder so.
Und das ist relativ klar, dass das so nicht kommen wird und deswegen ist auch
genau dieser Aspekt so, ja, machen wir mal, wie wäre es denn,
wenn wir das im Betriebssystem verankern?
Weil wenn du das jetzt nur auf dem Service verankerst, diese Pflicht,
jede Webseite muss sich fragen, jede App, dann ist das natürlich für alle total nervig.
Da würden selbst wahrscheinlich so EU-Kommissionsleute checken,
dass das echt nervig wird, wenn du die ganze Zeit so mit deinen Altersnachweis bringen musst.
Deswegen haben die sich überlegt, naja, wie wäre das denn, wenn wir die Betriebssysteme,
verpflichten, quasi so eine Art Gel, so eine Art Unlock zu implementieren.
Dass das Gerät quasi sagt, Achtung, ich bin noch nicht freigeschaltet.
Ich brauche noch die Watte-Variante. Bei mir hat noch keiner seinen Ausweis gezeigt.
Und dann hättest du quasi, weißt du, dann gehst du in den Laden,
kaufst dir so ein sagen wir mal ein iPhone oder ein Android.
Und dann sagt das erstmal so, ja, okay, hier, guten Tag. Und übrigens.
Wenn du bist jetzt hier im Kindermodus, falls dir das Internet auf einmal komisch
vorkommt, das liegt daran, dass du jetzt quasi wie ein Kind behandelt wirst.
Und wir könnten jetzt so einen Altersnachweis machen. Und dann,
ist dein Gerät quasi in der Lage, sich gegenüber anderen kryptografisch nachzuweisen
oder zu attestieren, dass hier ein Altersnachweis stattgefunden hat.
Dann kriegst du halt auf einmal die guten Apps im App Store,
dann kannst du auch wieder auf die Internetseiten gehen, die du sonst gar nicht
besuchen solltest und so.
Und dann hättest du quasi, wenn man das so nutzen würde, in einer solchen Architektur,
Dann wäre das eben auch ein einmaliger Akt. Dann könnten die Mitgliedstaaten
so mindestens ein kostenloses zertifiziertes Verfahren jeweils definieren.
Und wenn du das genutzt hast, dann haben alle Rechtssicherheit.
Weil das ist ja der Weg, wo auch wieder alle hinwollen.
Wenn du so ein Gesetz anzettelst, dann sitzen natürlich die ganzen Service-Provider,
die sagen, okay, scheiße.
Wie schaffen wir es, dass wir jetzt nicht am Ende wegen Jugendschutz irgendwelche
Millionenstrafen haben.
Und der Weg dahin ist natürlich alles klar. Definiert mir bitte welchen Service
die Leute nutzen sollen.
Idealerweise zwingt mich bitte gar nicht erst diesen Service zu nutzen,
sondern macht die Verifikation einmal auf dem Device, im Betriebssystem,
auf dem Android, auf dem Windows, auf dem MacOS, auf dem iOS, wo auch immer.
Ist mir scheißegal. Und gibt mir irgendein Zertifikat, irgendeine Signatur,
die ich einfach nur verifiziere und sagen kann, alles klar, du bist 18 oder nicht.
Was sagst du dazu?
Gibt es schon. Also ich meine, in macOS ist dieses Feature bereits integriert,
weil es in den USA in einigen Bundesstaaten vorgeschrieben ist, dass es so etwas gibt.
Es gab da auch eine Aushandlung, weil natürlich erst mal die politische Forderung
war von zeig mal deinen Ausweis und sag uns mal, wer du bist und dann checken wir das mal.
Also vollständigen Ausweis zeigen. Wobei dann Apple durchgesetzt hat,
dass sie dann eben diese Zero-Knowledge-Approach machen, so nach dem Motto,
das ist ja hier unser Kunde.
ICloud-Account, bla bla bla, Kreditkarte, alles was du vorhin auch schon genannt hast.
Wir wissen ja sozusagen, wer das ist und wir können dann eben gegenüber diesem
Dienst das entsprechend nachweisen, dass eben folgendes Alter erreicht wurde.
Also diese Funktionalitäten existieren, deswegen wecken die jetzt im Rahmen
solcher politischen Gesetzgebungsprozesse auch entsprechende Begehrlichkeiten.
Ich meine, in gewisser Hinsicht macht es ja auch Sinn, das so zu machen.
Wir hatten ja schon mehrfach über Altersverifikation gesprochen und das,
abgesehen von der Diskussion, ob wir sowas generell haben wollen, dass Dinge,
für Menschen, Kinder ab einem bestimmten Alter eingeschränkt wird,
ist halt klar, dass da, wo es irgendwie sinnvoll,
ist oder wo es, selbst wenn es vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll ist,
durchgesetzt wird, dass es dann natürlich auf jeden Fall mit so einem Zero-Knowledge-Proof,
also mit einem der Dienst, der das prüft,
kriegt nur gesagt, oder sagen wir mal, der Service letzten Endes,
der genutzt werden soll, der kriegt nur von einer anderen Entität gesagt,
dass das schon okay ist so.
Aber nicht jetzt automatisch auch Details vom Personalausweis,
Reisepass oder was auch immer in dem Moment eine Rolle spielt.
Genau, du könntest nämlich jetzt also,
Also wir kommen nachher zu den Folgen. Wenn du so etwas machen willst,
dann musst du es technisch auch so machen, weil die Alternative wäre,
okay, du zwingst jeden Service einen Altersnachweis zu machen,
dann hast du da das ganze Theater.
Und den Tracking und so weiter.
Wenn du es auf Netzwerkebene, DNS-Sperren oder sonst was, das ist auch absolut
zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Also machst du eine... machst du es zwischen dem Device und dem Service.
Für Apps ist es dann ganz besonders einfach.
Das kann Apple im Prinzip und ich nehme jetzt immer Apple als Beispiel oder
Google genauso. Das wird dann einmal auf dem Gerät gemacht.
Und dann hast du nämlich auch wunderschön die ganze Last bei Apple oder Google,
als diejenigen, die dieses Betriebssystem machen, die können dann an zentraler
Stelle potenzielle Schwächen- und Umgehungsmaßnahmen.
Ausmerzen. Und du hast gleichzeitig für, was weiß ich, Apps,
die sagen, hör mal, ich will gar nichts von dem Nutzer wissen.
Keine Ahnung, jetzt nehmen wir als Beispiel Signal.
Die wollen ja gar nicht wissen, wie du heißt, wie alt du bist oder sowas.
Die hätten dann quasi so eine OS-AP oder noch nicht mal. Die würden einfach
nur sagen, folgende Funktionalitäten gibt es, wenn das Gerät die Eigenschaft
hat, ich bin aber 18 und ansonsten gibt es sie nicht.
Da hast du wirklich ein technisches Ökosystem geschaffen.
Wo das funktioniert. Das ist die einzige sinnvolle technische Lösung.
Wenn man auf die sehr schlechte Idee kommt, so etwas zu machen.
Denn du zementierst damit ja auch vollständig das Monopol von,
in dem Fall, Apple und Google. Weil.
Also wie nehme ich beispielsweise jetzt mit meinem Linux on the Desktop.
Wie nehme ich da jetzt noch am Erwachsenen Internet teil, wenn das nicht eine,
in Anführungszeichen sichere,
Remote Attestation Möglichkeit hat, zu beweisen, dass es irgendwie ein,
dass eine Altersnachweis durchgeführt wurde.
Und warum ich da jetzt den Begriff Remote Attestation verwende,
du brauchst quasi etwas, also du hättest, also das Problem, was du lösen musst,
aus einer Security Perspektive ist, dass der Altersnachweis nicht gescholen werden kann.
Und dass der auch nicht gefälscht werden kann. Dass der auch nicht übertragbar
ist. Das ist immer die Anforderung bei so etwas. Das würdest du am Ende eigentlich
machen letztendlich mit einem Zertifikat. Das Zertifikat hat eine Gültigkeit.
Das ist signiert von jemandem.
In diesem einen Beispiel von Apple,
oder Google, die sagen, wir haben einen Altersnachweis gemacht und klappt.
Oder sie würden es potenziell vielleicht gar nicht mehr dem Service sagen müssen,
sondern sie liefern es einfach mit.
Es muss aber für den Service wiederum überprüfbar sein. Das heißt,
du würdest irgendetwas Kryptografisches machen, wo potenziell,
wenn der Key verloren geht oder in falsche Hände gerät, eher geeignet ist,
einen einmal durchgeführten Altersnachweis auf andere Geräte zu übertragen.
Oder zu kopieren. Und das musst du ja verhindern, weil sonst ist dein System
ja kaputt. Das heißt, du setzt auf jeden Fall irgendwie auf so ein TPM. Auf jeden Fall muss es,
ein sicheres Modul für die kryptografische Aufbewahrung von Schlüsseln in dem Gerät geben,
in dem dann dieser Altersnachweisschlüssel verwendet wird, mit dem dann signiert
wird, im Rahmen dieses Zero-Knowledge-Proof, ja, der Altersnachweis hat statt
von Altersnachweis gesagt, wir verraten trotzdem nicht die Idee.
Und es muss aber auf eine Weise implementiert sein, dass ich den Schlüssel nicht klauen und verwendet,
kopieren kann, irgendwo anders hin übertragen kann. Und damit wird es sehr,
sehr, sehr schwierig, weil solange du nicht wirklich quasi über ein Gerät verfügst, was,
ein solches TPM hat,
glaube ich, wird es zum Problem, an diesem Ökosystem noch teilzunehmen.
Ja, das wird fast eine Voraussetzung dafür, dass man überhaupt noch an irgendeinem
Ökosystem teilnehmen kann.
Richtig, und das lieferst du mit einer solchen Architektur, den großen Plattformen-Freihaus.
Du sagst im Prinzip voll geil,
wir schenken euch, dass ein großer Teil der interessanten Inhalte im Internet
nur noch über eure Devices problemlos zugänglich sind.
Angenommen, es gibt noch das Internet.
Und vor allem, ich meine, ich muss sagen, dieser Kids-Act ist wirklich so dermaßen überdreht.
Also ich meine, diese Liste ist ja wohl vollkommen irre.
Also da steht ja, das ist ja ein feuchter Fiebertraum von irgendwie allem,
was man sich nur irgendwie vorstellen kann. Und ich meine, die Implikation,
angenommen, das würde jetzt morgen beschlossen werden, was das nicht wird, aber angenommen.
Mit diesen Regeln irgendeine realistische Compliance hinzubekommen, ist eine Bürde.
Also jetzt mal abgesehen davon, dass hier auch viele nicht wünschenswerte Regelungen drin sind.
Aber selbst wenn man die alle für wünschenswert halten würde und wenn man sagt,
so ja, voll gut jetzt hier, Kinder total geschützt, nichts kann mehr passieren,
dann damit Compliance zu bekommen, erscheint mir einfach extrem unrealistisch.
Und wenn überhaupt es Systeme gibt,
also ein Mac OS hat es dann ein bisschen einfacher, ist aber auch nur ein kleiner
Teil in diesem ganzen Spiel und große Anbieter haben es natürlich auch einfacher,
weil sie ganz anders skalieren können.
Während halt so Systeme wie Mastodon als Social Network,
freie Linux-Desktop-Rechner, die man einfach mal so benutzt,
müssten dann im großen Maße auf so Third-Party-Dienste,
ausweichen, werden also quasi gezwungen, auf einmal Bezahldienste zu machen
für einen Dienst, der vielleicht eigentlich frei ist.
Und das dann nicht stemmen können oder auch nicht stemmen wollen,
weil ja auch administrativ da der Aufwand enorm steigt, weil die rechtliche
Unsicherheit, was passiert, wenn ich jetzt damit nicht compliant bin?
Wer ist dann irgendwie schuld? Ist das dann irgendwie der Admin und so weiter?
Wird der Verein aufgelöst? Was auch immer, was passiert dann?
Das würde halt einfach mal jegliche Entwicklung, abgesehen von großen Playern komplett erdrücken.
Also da ist dann halt einfach an Innovation in diesem Bereich überhaupt nicht mehr zu denken.
Ich glaube einen kleinen Aspekt würde ich noch anmerken.
Angenommen, ich betreibe eine Webseite.
Ja, und die ist, was weiß ich, da muss ich jetzt irgendwie, genau,
Mastodon. Ich habe einen Mastodon-Server.
Und ich muss jetzt, ich bin jetzt gezwungen, an diesem Age-Verification-Regime
teilzunehmen. Ja, geil sein.
Wenn das wirklich, also wenn du eine Architektur machst, die am Ende ihren Vertrauensanker
in einem TPM auf einem Device hat,
dann kannst du, also dann ist das wirklich in wenigen Zeilen Code geschrieben,
dass du dir eine Zertifikatskette geben lässt, die quasi gerade sagt,
so hier, zack, hier ist ein Altersnachweis durchgeführt worden.
Und das wäre dann potenziell, also ja, letztendlich wäre es so ein Config-Parameter in deinem Nginx oder,
in deinem Apache oder was auch immer, dein Elixir-Webserver, wie der heißt,
da würdest du potenziell, am Ende hättest du einfach nur so eine Reihe an,
Zertifikaten, von denen du eine Signatur akzeptierst und dann sagst du, alles in Ordnung.
Und ich glaube, genau das ist halt echt das Gefährliche, dass du das sehr schnell.
Zu einem technischen Standard erheben kannst, den dann eben,
Microsoft, Apple und Google problemlos erfüllen.
Und Meta.
Nee, nee, nee. Das Problem ist, glaube ich, eher die Device-Dependency.
Du zementierst das Monopol auf dem Device und machst aber die Adoption für die
Services da draußen sehr einfach.
Und das ist, also wenn die gleichen Leute, die rennen den ganzen Tag rum und
sagen, ne, hier, aber Digital Markets, wir müssen Monopole brechen und jetzt,
der Messenger, der muss jetzt, wir haben uns überlegt,
Befreiungsschlag, Befreiungsschlag, europäische Unabhängigkeit,
der Messenger, der muss jetzt interoperabel sein, wir brechen das jetzt auf,
wir zerschlagen euch, wir brechen eure Macht, oh ne, doch nicht,
passt auf, wir haben uns überlegt,
wir machen so ein Remote Attestation Framework, was wir einfach gesetzlich verpflichtend
machen, was alle einfach fett in eure Plattformen bindet. Was haltet ihr davon?
Außerdem schaffen wir Rechtssicherheit für euch.
Das ist völlig irre.
Keine so gute Idee.
Und was dann natürlich passiert,
Also der Default, was wir ja hier sagen, Safety by Default heißt einfach nur so,
unverifiziert heißt Kind. Also das Erste, was du mit dem Computer machst,
den packst du aus oder ein Device, was dir verkauft, packst es aus und weißt
nach, dass du 18 bist, damit es benutzbar ist.
Und Junge, Junge, Was für eine schlechte Idee.
Ja, also ich kann dir das gar nicht sagen.
Achso, genau, worauf ich noch hinaus wollte, ist, das nächste Problem,
was du dann lösen willst, ist,
jetzt gehen natürlich die Eltern hin und sagen nach dem vierten Tag,
wo das Kind nur eine Stunde Candy Crush spielen konnte, sagen die, scheiße, Alter.
Hier kriegst du lieber ein Gerät ab 18, als dass du, als setze ich mich hier
weiter dieser EU-Vorgabe von einer Stunde Screentime mit der Sendung mit der
Maus oder was unterwerfe und schalten das frei.
Die nächste Idee, die dann natürlich kommt, ist, da muss das Device halt ab
und zu mal wieder nachfragen.
Oder man könnte ja auch sagen, wir verpflichten das Device, Plausibilitätsanalysen
zu machen. Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel mit deinem iPhone am laufenden Band Erwachsene
fotografiert werden und irgendwie so die Kinder-Selfies fehlen.
Dein Gerät ist 18 aber es werden die ganze Zeit nur Kinder-Selfies gepostet
dann könnte man ja als EU sagen auf Apple, merkst du doch dass da,
eine Circumvention stattgefunden hat, da verpflichten wir dich aber jetzt dagegen
vorzugehen Plausibilitätsanalysen wird hier etwa,
wurde hier etwa einem Kind ein Gerät freigeschaltet, obwohl es ein Kind ist
und das rennt jetzt hier als 18-Jähriger durchs Internet und könnte theoretisch
mit Ungemach konfrontiert werden.
Oder mit TikTok-Videos.
TikTok-Videos, ja.
Also es ist schon wirklich irrsinnig, was das für ein protektionistischer Gedanke
ist und für was für einen Wahnsinn der führt. Ja.
Also das Ganze ist jetzt erstmal vorgelegt worden vor einer Woche oder so oder 17, 14 Tagen.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt ein Vorschlag der Kommission, das ist eine absolute Maximalforderung.
Das muss natürlich jetzt erstmal im Parlament durchgenudelt werden,
da wird das sicherlich nicht so gut ankommen.
Aber wie bei all diesen Gesetzesvorhaben muss man halt jetzt gut hinschauen
und schauen, was am Ende dort in Kompromissen dann vielleicht doch wieder übrig bleibt,
wenn dieser ganze Vorstoß nicht zurückgenommen wird. Aber da habe ich irgendwie
relativ wenig Hoffnung, zumindest jetzt erstmal kurzfristig,
dass es gleich wieder abgesagt wird.
Es ist ein bisschen viel. Dass das jetzt ausgerechnet unter der Führung von
Ursula von der Leyen passiert, hat natürlich auch so ein Geschmäckle.
Wir erinnern uns vielleicht noch so vage an die gute alte Zensursolar-Debatte
rund um die Stoppschilder im Internet. Das war ja sozusagen ihr Ding damals,
als sie noch im Ministeramt war.
Und das hat ja auch nicht so gut funktioniert. Da wurden dann so DNS-Sperren
und so weiter gemacht. Wir müssen ja irgendwie was für die Kinder tun.
Im Prinzip ist das jetzt die neue Version davon.
Da kannst du es nicht lassen, der Ursel.
Und ich meine, wir diskutieren so Sachen immer so, als wäre das so der,
als würde es damit enden.
Aber die werden ja auch nicht aufhören, zum Beispiel mit ihrer Chatkontrolle und so.
Und das kannst du natürlich, wenn man das ein bisschen verbindet mit,
was wir vorher gesagt haben, dann
sagst du halt, ach so, ihr wollt Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung? In Ordnung.
Ihr wollt Chatkontrolle nicht für Erwachsene? Alles klar, finden wir auch in Ordnung.
Dann zwingen wir die jetzt halt in das Betriebssystem.
Da musst du nämlich, wenn du jetzt eine App von potenziell,
jugendgefährdenden Kontaktmöglichkeiten sind, und du hast nicht jemand gezeigt,
ich bin aber ja 18, dann musst du die Betriebssystem-API nutzen,
wo ein Betriebssystem-LLM darüber wacht,
dass da die Kinder auf den Bildern alle angezogen sind und so weiter und so fort.
Also das Schlimme an dieser ganzen Sache ist, dass es halt tatsächlich ...
Einige Probleme löst, aber eben auf eine sehr, sehr unkluge Weise.
Insbesondere, wenn man meint, man wäre die Europäische Union und wollte sich
noch gegen irgendwelche Monopole oder Plattformen wehren.
Kommen wir zu den Terminen.
Ja, einen hast du ja schon genannt, den willst du jetzt bestimmt noch mal nennen, wie ich dich kenne.
Den LMP-Salon. Das ist der nächste Tim. Achso, den wollte ich. Der ist doch, warte mal.
Den haben wir auch schon mal erwähnt, aber wir haben noch nichts Konkretes genannt.
Genau, wir wurden aber gefragt, wann wir denn dafür die Tickets verkaufen. Der ist ja am...
Wann ist der denn nochmal?
Im Oktober war das, ne?
Ja, also ist nicht mehr so lange hin. Musste schon...
Am 11 Oktober.
Musst du dir was freihalten.
Oh krass. Und ich habe jetzt gedacht, wann wollen wir denn dann den Vorverkauf machen?
Am 5. Oktober.
Echt am fünften? Also nur sechs Tage vorher? Ja, reicht eigentlich, ne?
Ja.
Dann habt ihr auch Planungssicherheit. Und wir auch.
Genau. Ne, wir kommen jetzt nicht vorher dazu. Ich bin unterwegs und pipapo,
dieses und jenes. Aber am 5. Oktober geht's los und dann kauft ihr ein paar
Tickets und dann sehen wir uns am 11. Und dann quatschen wir so ein bisschen.
Genau. Konzept haben wir in der letzten Sendung erklärt. Kleiner Kreis,
so um die 30 Leute in einer kleinen gemütlichen,
Location in Neukölln und zwar in der E-Stube und wir,
haben diesen Ticket verkauft, machen wir deswegen, damit wir diesen Raum nicht
überfüllen und ihr sicher sein
könnt, dass ihr da reinkommt und wir sicher sein können, dass ihr kommt.
Deswegen launchen wir diesen kleinen Ticket vor Verkauf in dem Sinne um am 5. Oktober um 12 Uhr.
Habe ich jetzt mal entschieden, um ein bisschen Druck auf den Tim zu erhöhen.
Und wir haben dann auch Tickets zu unterschiedlichen Preisstufen ermäßigt,
Standard und Supporter.
Aber wie gesagt, bei den Tickets geht es uns eher darum, eine Verbindlichkeit
zu haben, eurer Teilnahme und eures Besuchs. Gebt ihr auch einfach ab, wenn ihr nicht kommt.
Und gleichzeitig eine kleine Spendenmöglichkeit für euch zu bieten,
wenn ihr zu diesem Kosten des Events irgendwie beitragen wollt.
Das ist der 5. Oktober.
Dann ist vom 30. Oktober bis 1. November ist die FIFCON.
FIFCON 42, man muss es schon das genau sagen.
Aber ist das wirklich die 42?
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die 42 ist. Ich weiß nur, dass auf der Webseite FIFCON
42 steht und ich nehme natürlich das Internet für voll. und wenn da steht FIFCON
42, dann wird das schon seinen Grund haben.
Meinst du echt, die haben so viele FIF-Könne schon gemacht?
Ich weiß nicht, ob die zählen. Vielleicht heißt ja jede FIF-Könne.
Achso, wenn ich auf den anderen Link klicke, dann steht hier FIF-Könne 26.
Das ist ja auch sehr konsistent hier auf der Webseite.
Also auf der eigentlichen Webseite, auf 20.26.fifkon.de steht LattenSound FIF-Könne
42. Eine Konferenz des FIF.
Wenn man auf Ticket klickt, dann ist FIF-Könne 26. Also ihr habt jetzt sozusagen...
Nicht, dass man da auf einmal bei der falschen Fischkann ist.
Jetzt sind wir wieder bei der Zeitmaschinengeschichte. Da muss so dringend reguliert werden.
Ja?
Ja,
also da haben wir jetzt hier eine Differenz von 16.
Und jetzt wissen wir noch nicht mal, was...
Also vom 30. Oktober bis 1. November...
Hat die FIFCON 42 stattgefunden gehabt werden.
Zu haben. Vielleicht fängt sie ja auch 26 an und ist erst 42 zu Ende.
Das geht jetzt einfach so. 16 Jahre lang.
Wenn man da in so ein Zeitloch fällt, dann bist du 42 Jahre lang im Loch.
Oder nee, das sind ja gar nicht. Es sind ja nur 6 Zeitmaschinen müssen dringend reguliert werden.
Also, dass der FIF da jetzt auch so reingrätscht, das ist jetzt auch wirklich,
Da wird jetzt eine politische Debatte aufgerufen, die gar nicht dran war.
Aber jetzt haben wir den Salat. Na gut, also ihr werdet das dann irgendwie gelöst
bekommen, sicherlich mit der...
Es sind ja alles Informatikerinnen und Informatiker, die wissen ja eigentlich,
wovon sie reden. Wo ist denn das eigentlich?
Also wo fängt es an?
Delphi.
Man ist ja jetzt nicht 16 Jahre lang nur an einem Ort.
Im Delphi.
Im Delphi, da waren wir auch schon mal.
LNP 200 haben wir da gemacht.
Das ist ein schönes, altes Theater und sehr schicke Location.
Da werdet ihr sicherlich eine Menge Spaß haben. Der Slogan ist keine Panik,
Resilienz in der Polykrise.
Also das ist sozusagen für euch keine Duma.
Für euch Duma genau der richtige Schutzraum, wo ihr euch dann aufhalten könnt.
Keine Panik, Resilienz in der Polykrise.
Also da könnt ihr euch auf jeden Fall abhärten. Wenn ihr euch aber richtig durcheinander
bringen wollt, dann müsst ihr natürlich zu Linus gehen.
Unbeschwingt durch den nuklearen Winter. Resilienz nach dem Erstschlag.
Und am 17. November dann im Mehringhof-Theater. Funfacts-Ticket vor Verkauf
ist auch schon gestartet.
Und Funfacts-Bandenmitglied und so weiter wollte ja auch alles werden.
Genau.
Klickt euch das alles, solange das noch geht, mit euren nicht freigeschalteten iPhones.
Ja, besonders ihr 13-Jährigen.
Ja, also wenn ihr 13 seid, ihr müsst die Tickets innerhalb von einer Stunde
kaufen, sonst ist die Bildschirmzeit vorbei.
Hoffen wir mal, dass die Webseite da mitspielt.
Ach ja, naja, am Ende sitzt du nur noch mit Erwachsenen rum. Linus.
Ja.
Ja, wäre auch mal nicht schlecht. Wobei, die benehmen sich immer mehr wie Kinder.
Ja, eben. Ich dachte auch gerade so, kindischer wird es dann auch nicht mehr.
Kinder sind mir teilweise ein bisschen lieber inzwischen.
Ja, das geht jetzt leider nicht.
Ja, die sind ein bisschen, die
gehen einfach so kindlich, unbeschwingt und resilient durch die Polykrise.
Ja, die haben die goldene Zwanziger, ich sag's ja. Warum werde ich dafür eigentlich gescholten?
Ja, das weiß ich. Das weiß keiner.
Das versteht auch keiner. Naja, das werdet ihr dann in der Zukunft wissen.
Das könnt ihr dann überprüfen mit eurer Zeitmaschine.
Also schwupp auf die Zeitmaschine, bevor sie reguliert wird.
Leute, das war's. Wir verabschieden uns von euch in dieser Woche und hoffen
euch dann bald auch live zu sehen und dann auch natürlich indirekt sozusagen
in der nächsten Sendung.
Könnt ihr uns dann hören, also andersrum.
Bis bald. Tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.